merci la parole l'état monsieur elie à
bout merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à madame la ministre
des affaires sociales et de santé et je
voudrais associer les députés de mon
groupe
madame la ministre comment réussir une
réforme sans dialogue
une réforme avec une absence
significative de cap de gouvernance et
d'objectifs communs aucune réflexion de
fond sur la démographie médicale sur la
décentralisation de notre système de
santé sur l'inégal répartition
territoriale des médecins
aucune réflexion de fond sur le parcours
du 1 sur la nécessaire coordination
public-privé ville hôpital médical
médico-social aucune aucune réflexion de
fond sur le métier de soignant de plus
en plus emboliser par des tâches
administratives
ce temps administratif rouge le temps
médical
ainsi vous savez mais certainement sans
le vouloir madame la ministre crée un
fossé énorme entre votre gouvernement et
l'ensemble des professionnels de santé
au lieu de débloquer le verrou vous
avaient cadenassé le système pour preuve
pour preuve votre projet de conférence
de santé
demain mais il est mort né la quasi
totalité des organisations
représentatives de gauche et de droite
en seront absentes
il s'agit là d'un camoufler si j'ose
dire d'une conférence hémiplégique
je ne vous pose aucune question sur le
fond car je connais malheureusement
votre aptitude à contourner les choses
et ne pas y répondre
je vous interroge sur une question
simple très simple comment faites vous
pour avoir toujours raison tout seul
merci
la parole est à madame marisol touraine
ministre des affaires sociales de la
santé des droits des femmes
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
elie aboud
demain je ne serai pas tout seul demain
il y aura plus de 450 participants à la
grande conférence de la santé il y aura
200 institutions et associations qui
participeront aux débats qu et ont
participé aux débats depuis le mois de
juillet dernier
il y aura les représentants des
praticiens hospitaliers des sages-femmes
des infirmiers libéraux comme public des
masseurs kinésithérapeutes des
orthophonistes des psychomotriciens des
orthoptistes des pédicures podologues il
y aura les représentants des hôpitaux
publics vous plaît s'il vous plaît
des cliniques privées il y aura tous les
syndicats de jeunes médecins qui à ma
connaissance ne se destine pas tous à
l'exercice à l'hôpital et vous le savez
très bien mesdames et messieurs les
députés le syndicat mg france a annoncé
vient d'annoncer sa présence à cette
conférence
l'enjeu il est de faire en sorte que nos
réflexions et nos propositions ne porte
pas uniquement sur la réorganisation de
notre système de santé parce que venant
d'un autre que vous monsieur abou
j'aurais compris que l'on dise que rien
n'était fait pour lutter contre la
désertification médicale ou là
entre le public et le privé mais vous
étiez présent lors des débats que nous
avons eus sur les sujets qui permettent
d'avoir des groupement hospitalier de
territoire des parcours de st de soins
et le recentrage du médecin génère dans
notre système de santé mais au delà nous
devons travailler pour améliorer la
formation des futurs professionnels
médicaux et paramédicaux améliorer leurs
conditions d'exercice et c'est le sens
des travaux qui se mènent depuis le mois
de juillet dernier et le premier
ministre demain on sera des propositions
concrètes qui vont améliorer la
formation et les conditions d'exercice
de moeurs et de viols